the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences 25th annual Academy Awards now
ladies and gentlemen you are looking
west on Hollywood Boulevard
perhaps population changes have swung
the motion picture industry away from
this historic street somewhat but it
will always remain a little nostalgia
and memory something like 42nd Street
and broad here are the stands and there
is the marquee down there in front of
the theater the group of people still
coming in Tony Curtis and Janet Lee
Marge and Gower champion Leslie Caron
and her husband mr. Hormel here in the
Pantages tonight is the world's most
glamorous audience nearly 3,000 strong
all waiting to see the Oscars handed out
and almost all are either rooting for
friends or keeping their fingers crossed
for themselves if you look closely in
there you can see some of your favorites
the screen most of the nominees will be
present some of course as you've heard
her in are in New York I see Merle
Oberon sitting down there just to the
right corner of the screen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences
mr. Charles Brackett
[Music]
[Applause]
fellow members of the Academy guests
friends everywhere welcome to this very
special birthday in honor of the
occasion all the presenters tonight are
to be Academy Award winners a miniature
Oscar was once voted to a man for his
various special services to the Academy
as a master of ceremonies is to be our
master of ceremonies tonight ladies and
gentlemen mr. Bob Hope
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much mr. Brackett good
evening ladies and gentlemen welcome to
suspense I am very very very happy to be
here at the Academy Awards 25th annual
award show this is hollywood's most
exciting giveaway show and i want to
thank all the wrestlers for relinquish
their time
so we can give these awards just showed
you there's nothing the one group of
actors won't do for another as mr.
Brackett pointed out this is indeed a
wedding of two great entertainment
mediums were the motion pictures and
television and with Oscar 25 years old
it's high time he got married while it's
true that he has a child bride it's a
comfort to note that the kid is loaded
in fact the bride's father is picking up
the tab for this wedding reception
but isn't it exciting to know that a lot
of these glamorous stars are going to be
in your home's tonight
all over America housewives are turning
to their husbands and saying put on your
shirt Joan Crawford is coming television
that's where movies go when they die
well I want to say that tonight you
regular television watchers will see
movie stars you've never seen before
new faces like Mary Pickford Janet
Gaynor Ronald Colman and Jean Hersholt I
hope you will give these youngsters the
same welcome you give your current
favorites Peeta Barrett George Arliss
Elmo Lincoln Clive Brooke liya be putty
and Francis X Bushman after all I'm not
here to belittle television because you
can't ignore an industry that has
brought Fame to chef Milani fortune to
Hopalong Cassidy and perpetual youth to
the Bowery Boys just imagine how Leo
Garcia's kid must feel watching TV and
finding out his old man as younger than
he is don't get me wrong
television is wonderful today you can
sit home and see Broadway shows go to
church in your own living room you don't
have to go outside for anything I was
born in a farm where you have to go
outside for everything
but seven movie companies are still
stubborn about recognizing television
Jack Warner still refers to TV as that
furniture that stares back but movies
are still your best entertainment it's
all movies ladies and gentlemen and
it'll always be your best entertainment
if you don't think so ask Joe DiMaggio
you don't see him going out with Kukla
Fran and Ollie but I want to say for the
country that this is a big night for
Hollywood I've never seen so many
Cadillacs mink coats diamonds emeralds
rubies ermine wraps it looks like a PTA
meeting in Texas
[Applause]
and it's a gay handsome crowd here
tonight but there's an undercurrent of
nervousness the whole thing is like a
big maternity ward everybody is
expecting and keep your eyes on the
losers tonight as they applaud the
winners you'll see great understanding
great sportsmanship great acting some of
the losers take it pretty hard last year
one actor tried to kill himself by
jumping off Gary Cooper fortunately my
parachute opened just in time but I have
been master of ceremonies at five or six
of these affairs and I get a big kick
out of it and of course I like to be
here just in case you can never tell
some year there might be one left over
look at those Oscars isn't that
something looks like Betty Davis's
garage
no I think it's rather silly I mean all
this fuss about winning one of those
Oscars what are they just a bookend with
a sneer don't glare at me you melt it
down Stevenson buttons but I want to
tell you this is the last year that the
statuette will be presented in this form
next year it'll be wearing glasses I
want to tell you that everything in
Hollywood is excited over third
dimension it's the biggest thing to hit
the movie since s will be DeMille began
rewriting the Bible and it's hard to say
it's hard to say what effect
three-dimensional pictures will have on
the world the next generation of
children may be born with square
eyeballs